In this video we will talk about boxplot charts.
Boxplots are used quite frequently.
Particularly within stock analysis and statistics.
.
Most stock charters
have boxplots in their sortiement.
First, however, we need to understand how to do it
and reading a box plot using
of these data.
First, we must put them in order,
We do this as we have to find some medians
to make our box plot.
Let's put the numbers in order.
It seems that 49 is the lowest number.
In addition, we have an additional 2 49.
They thus constitute the first 3 numbers in the number sequence.
Now let's see if we have some 50s?
We have it - 50 is available twice.
1, a total of 2 50s.
.
Do we have some 51s?
As far as I can see, 51 is only 1 time.
51 is there once.
Do we have some 52?
We have a 52.
.
Some 53?
We have 1, 2 53s.
53 and 53.
Here is a 54.
There are no more of them.
There are no 55's,
but here is a 56.
There is